this is insane and this is like a
private club for him he's worked with
the server's before and accepted a
portion of the tips the heart [ __ ]
hell
he's taking their bloody tips this guy
is mad I can't believe this
he doesn't pay them and then he takes
their tips I gotta talk to him
how are we Barbara how are you today
good I just had of interest is it true
that Robert takes a percentage of the
tips yes it does yeah what percentage of
tips does he take what we get he gets
the same as you yeah it's really hard to
keep track of the tips I the bookkeeping
it seems inconsistent so why is he
touching the tips did he do the same
thing for New Year's they felt that
because they need to cover part of the
band that they took the tips off are
vitamins that's why we don't make
anything happen
I know nur has no right to take the
staffs tips and with all the room and
food coms Robert is giving his friends
it's no wonder the inn is struggling the
staff shouldn't be subsidizing the end
so Robert knees friends get to live the
high life for free it's sickening I have
to confront him and figure out this
nonsense I just had a look round and I
just I am flabbergasted and I'd be
really frank and I'm gonna try stay so
calm but if I smell but yes that you
start going into denial I'm gonna let
rip again I studied your reservations
last November December 49 rooms were
given out for free and on top of that
they ate they drank for nothing I'm not
even tipping and I'm just [ __ ] you
didn't tell me why I thought I needed to
have somebody here rather than having
two other guests in the hotel all by
themselves to have more energy now I can
it worse not only do your friends not
leave tips but when people do to the
stuff you take your share on nights that
I work I did take - that is disgusting
why do you think you are right to that I
have tried to work with my staff to
teach them that this is the way I want
service dog so bad I take a percentage
of the tips based on the amount of work
that I do and who does the books from
those tapes re but if I'm doing their
job and I can't get it across to them
you're the owner you know they had
Busboys you know the barman you're the
[ __ ] owner what I was saying wasn't
getting through so the psychology was
that if I started to take tips they
would maybe pay attention to that it's
insane and the worst management model
I've ever heard in my entire life
do you honestly need a 70 year old
lady's tips so 15 20 grands worth of
complimentary rooms in a food in a two
month period I'm just make sense I have
to tell you that the reason I did that
was because I thought that they would at
least tip my staff but they didn't tip
your staff sorry to piss on your bum
fire well then I won't call my friends
and I will tell them look what happened
whoever got the [ __ ] balls to call
your friends and ask them to leave a tip
yes I do
coolant
and ask them I thought at least at a
generosity you would have left a couple
hundred dollars tip for the team
Dana its Robert you stayed here recently
and I was under the impression that you
and Greg left a tip did you leave a tip
no no but you said you were going to
send additional tip I think my time to
come here that was one of the things
that I was hoping you had done I left
the money with you wait a minute there's
others to call - Gordon OH - Gordon has
left
he thinks I'm stealing my staff's tips
unbelievable
hey ray it's Robert did you tip the
staff cuz they're telling people that
they haven't been tipped I left the
money with you oh so I need to do that I
have somehow lost that [ __ ] in here
Gordon left thinking I'm a liar I feel
as if I'm me I'm at the end of my rope
I mean I'm gonna lose everything I'm
gonna have to start all over again if
this doesn't work and don't seem like do
it I know I can't do it
[Music]